your attention please the new king  getaway package charter flight will soon  be arriving at the deserted island  [Music]  [Music]  originally we announced this title of a  20-19 release however we need to change  its release date to March 20th of 2020  to ensure that the game is the best it  can be  we must ask you to wait a little longer  than we thought  we hope you look forward to the latest  installment of Animal Crossing now on  Nintendo treehouse live the games  producer mr. Nogami and the director ms  Kyogoku will come on  for a live demonstration of some early  moments in the game so please stick  around until it starts by the way there  are many different types of games coming  to Nintendo Square